hello and welcome to sarula show Precure  I'm earlier and this is my side Bill we  have Big Show today  so cool Iceland's number one company Duo  is here football and grotto  you have a good weekend part yes I  visited my elf Shrine Uli  I can't continue with that is that is  this a recurring bit they do is there  some context I'm missing Maybe  context like LSD but that's the context  in which I need to be viewing this  particular skit so it seems that the SNL  kind of fluctuates between banal  politically correct tripe and then stuff  that's weird  but forgets that weird in and of itself  isn't funny you have to be funny as well  as weird uh you still have to make jokes  within the weirdness you want weird I'll  give you weird weird weird weird